fifteen percent what is fifteen percent
or fifteen percent is the percentage
body masters made up by proteins in the
average human being so they're pretty
important right code by genes proteins
from the basis of living tissue so cells
are truly the building blocks of life
then proteins are kind of support beams
that stop the house when falling down
they play a central role in biological
processes catalyzing reactions within
our body the transporting molecules
around the body or the transmitting
messages from cell to cell they also
help to regulate hormones and enzymes to
mean just a few of the critical
functions of proteins perform for these
reasons protein research is very
critical for understanding Biological
processes and the process underlying
health and disease I'm Paul Belcher on
april fifth this year 2017 I'll be your
host for local protein research live
event hosted by lavaridge we have a
fantastic agenda lined up for you which
is your opportunity to learn about a
range of critical protein research
techniques we have some fantastic
speakers and presentations covering
topics from genome research which
includes RNAi and chris burke after nine
which hopefully always a really hot air
in biology right now we also have
experts and you can also learn about the
latest and greatest in recombinant
protein production and purification or
learn about the latest from our experts
on protein detection validation and
quantitation all alternatively my our
expertise you can come and learn about
what's new in a heart in label-free
interaction analysis our speakers truly
are experts in their field so this is
your opportunity to learn from them and
take this information back to your labs
and apply it to your own research in
addition to the presentations we have
learning booths where you can get the
latest information on a technique of
your interest or walk through to post
the presentation or engage in live chat
with some of our subject matter experts
will be present so this is your chance
to get those nagging questions answered
by our panel of experts it's gonna be a
fantastic event I'm really excited by it
and
hope to see you there so see you late
Paul fifth by